yeah confirmation of who this terrorist
suspect shot dead is he was sooo - a man
who was from Harrow in North London a
man who was jailed in December of 2018
for the possession of extremist material
also the possession of some bomb-making
materials actually the authorities were
so concerned about his extremist
proclivities that within 24 hours of
being alerted to his activities they had
moved in and arrested and then he was
jailed and released just halfway through
that rather short sentence back out on
the streets just relatively recently
what we don't know is what the
particular restrictions around his
release from prison where whether he was
subject to any kind of a curfew whether
he was denied access to the Internet and
allowed to only associate with people
who are not known extremists that those
are normally the the types of
restrictions for a number of terrorist
offenders it depends of course on the
seriousness of the offenses they were
originally jailed for the despite the
concerns over him he was jailed for
offences which were at the lower end of
the scheme the terrorists scale of
things so it wasn't attack planning as
such but certainly deemed to be a
dangerous individual he was put under we
understand surveillance relatively
recently but that was uptick to involve
armed officers as well when they became
more concerned about his potential for
violence but still of course the
question to be answered
this evening is why he was allowed out
into the street in a public area with
armed officers following him obviously
then to go on and carry out an attack
did the police have any inclination as
to whether this attack was imminent and
if that's the case why didn't they move
in intervene earlier and arrest him it's
always a balancing act for the
authorities go too early you risk not
getting enough evidence to put before
the courts and
put him back in prison go too late and
potentially he could be looking at this
type of situation here so those
questions still to be answered
you